their pockets children safely in school
workers safely back to work it's a
remarkable
historic transformative piece of
legislation
which goes a very long way to crushing
the virus
and solving our economic crisis
it's interesting to me to see what i'm
hearing on the floor during the pro-act
debate
how the republicans are talking about
their
tax scam 1.9 trillion dollars
in their tax scam 83 of the benefits to
the top one percent
and this bill same amount of money 1.9
trillion dollars overwhelmingly helping
america's working families
you'll hear more about that from
our colleagues as the next couple of
days go by
but i just wanted to join members of our
top leadership
in just giving you an update as to where
we are
and that the rules committee has
finished its work
its work on something that in the 33
years that i have been in congress and
up until now the affordable care act
has been the most consequential
legislation
that i have been a part of this is
definitely on a par with that
if not to exceed it in terms of its
impact
on many more uh poor people in our
country
with that i'm pleased to yield to mr our
distinguished a
democratic leader who knows more about
this schedule than any of us for any
other information or any uh
bragging rights about this important
legislation
it's not only provisions it's pieces of
bills
mr richie neil has about a trillion
dollars in money in people's pockets
right and including
the pension piece of it which is a piece
of legislation that went a long way
to uh to meet the needs of
so many people in our country but that
just another example barbara lee talked
this morning about the equity piece and
how
this legislation addresses the
inequality of the
of how healthcare and the vaccine and
all the rest would be distributed
a piece of legislation she and others
had put together
in any event all of it excellent
all of it fair all of it an opportunity
for us to grow the economy
by investing in the people for the
people
and i might say for our recovering
colleagues who have they say no to the
vote and they
show up at the ribbon cuttings or the
presentations
i was president of senate back in 1870
in the state of maryland and people
would rush up to me and say i need this
in the budget i need this in the budget
because it was a unified document one
like appropriation bills
and so okay well let's see if we can do
that so it's in the budget
and then of course they vote no so why
don't you vote no i said well i couldn't
vote for the budget
but you asked me if you put something in
there well yeah you did and i appreciate
that but i can't vote for this
so yes they'll be at the ribbon cuttings
they'll be there saying the schools are
open kids are in school isn't that great
yes it is great 130 billion dollars
later
in this bill and they voted against it
people have jobs small businesses are
open
vaccines are getting in arms and they'll
say
isn't that great they'll be at the
vaccine delivery point
but they won't have voted for this bill
but let there be no mistake
this is not an unusual performance for
our republican colleagues
nancy and i and rich and uh
jim clyburn have been here i don't think
you were here in 2009
well you were here in 2010 okay uh
zero
zero a bill that bernanke said would
keep us out of a depression
ben bernanke respected by all sides
this bill is i agree with the speaker
we all worked on the affordable care
health care bill
and the affordable care act was a
extraordinary piece of legislation
it took a long time for the american
people to understand how much value it
was to them and their families
but they've done that now and they will
certainly
didn't take the time on this bill
however
where we have over 70 percent of the
american people think this bill ought to
be passed
and the majority of the republican party
thinks this bill ought to be passed i
don't know who our republican colleagues
are listening to
but let me say and my job is sort of
focus in on the economy the economic
need for this bill this big and bold
legislation fills an urgent need for our
economy
nearly 10 million americans are out of
work compared to last march
10 million americans more than 163
thousand
small businesses shut their doors
between march and september of last year
this will help rescue a number of them
maybe not all but a large number that's
800 businesses a day
closing and laying off workers the
senate has now taken action the house
will pass this bill tomorrow
and send it to the president's desk
economists and public health experts
agree that we need
substantial relief this is not a
controversy in the economic community
they know that we need this
it's not just another temporary relief
measure like the ones enacted under the
trump administration
which by the way five bills passed
in a bipartisan fashion what was the
difference
one difference
republican president democratic
president
tarp democratic i mean republican
president
we got a significant number of
republicans not the majority
obama came in they changed had nothing
to do with substance and everything to
do with politics
mark zandi chief economist at moody's
analytics said that
we need a plan to quote get to the other
side of this crisis
this not only gets us to the other side
of the crisis
it really starts healing
the wounds that have been caused by this
crisis
a joint analysis conducted by brookings
in the hamilton project showed that the
american rescue plan
would bring a four percent growth in gdp
that's growth many years we haven't had
four percent gdp
this is growth in the gdp
uh this year but that without it
without this bill real gdp would quote
remain
below the pre-pandemic level for the
next several
years that's why the american people are
for this bill
they may not know the specifics of it
but their gut tells them
america needs this bill that's why this
bill provides families and small
businesses the relief they need to stay
afloat until we defeat this pandemic
once this bill is passed as it will be
tomorrow and sent to the president
we will send it to president bind to be
signed into law so that the
administration
can get these resources out to
communities to help businesses reopen
safely
to help americans until they can get
back to work and kids back in school
and shots in arms
this bill is an extraordinary piece of
legislation that will make
an extraordinary difference in the
health and well-being
of americans and america it's now my
privilege to yield to somebody who's
been a fighter all
his life for little people
for people who need a voice who people
needed a strong person to stand up and
say look at them and help them make them
uh have a better life
in pursuit of happiness my friend jim
clyburn of south carolina thank you very
much
mr leader madam speaker and my other
distinguished colleagues i don't think
the headline that we saw in the
washington post this morning is
appropriately by any means
in this article it talks about what this
legislation does
for black farmers and went on to say
this may be the biggest
help that black farmers have gotten
since the civil rights act
now all we have to do is took a hard
look
at the legislation and you will see
exactly what they're
talking about now a lot of times we talk
about
1890 now i know what the 1890 program is
uh it's a reference to um
black colleges
in the former slave states
we all remember i think the speaker has
talked about this
several times about abraham lincoln
signed the land grant
legislation um
but because of the times in which we
lived
clemson university in my state the lion
grant school first one was cornell
and of course people who look like me
could not attend
clemson so they came back and passed
another
land grant bill in 1890
for the former slave states this
legislation takes a look
at the work of those 1890 schools
and the discrimination had taken place
with black farmers i used to run the
south carolina commission
for farm workers and
i can tell you i'm well aware
of the inequities that existed in that
system
this legislation tackles that issue
like no legislation we have had
in my lifetime
and i think that alone
makes it worthwhile but it doesn't stop
there by any means
this legislation also tackles the issue
that we've had over the last several
years
with rural hospitals
this legislation goes straight to the
heart of that matter
and allows help rural hospitals
especially those
who are taxed with having to respond to
covert 19.
this lesson has somewhere around 7
billion to assist these hospitals
that's why if you look you will see
76 percent of the american people
support this legislation
and then that number 71 of independents
support this legislation 60
of republicans support this legislation
this is bipartisan legislation it may
not satisfy the protestants
on both sides of the capitol but it
satisfies
republicans 30 republican
mayors wrote in support of this
legislation
to me it is the best piece of
bipartisan legislation that i've seen
here in a long long time
and with that i'll hear you assistant
speaker
catherine clark thank you so much
i share the speakers excitement over
this
transformative bill and i am so grateful
and honored to be
up here with chairman yarmouth and
chairman neal
and grateful for your work and
leadership and that of your committee
and your incredible staff
and to the majority leader and mr whip
uh thank you for shepherding this bill
through
and to our speaker you always put the
children first
you center our work and our values
around children
and women and children have been hurt so
so deeply during this pandemic
it has been revealed through this
pandemic the house of cards
that is the foundation for women in this
economy and this bill addresses
those needs women's have women have lost
significantly more jobs
than men since the pandemic began
eviscerating more than 30 years of
progress
in the labor force in just one year
over 2 million women were pushed out of
the workforce
1 million working moms and many of those
are women of color 12 million
children in our country are going to bed
hungry
this bill provides transformative and
historic
solutions it not only will meet the
immediate needs
but it ensures that we will have a more
inclusive economy going forward
vaccines in the arms to get children
safely back to school
fourteen hundred dollar payments that
will benefit
eighty five percent of adults and
children in this country
an expanded tax credit that will cut
child poverty in half and lift nearly 12
million people out of poverty
we will boost funding for programs that
protect survivors
of gender-based violence housing and
food assistance
extended unemployment assistance
child care help not only for the child
care
industry but for parents so they can
deal with the high cost of child care
and get back to work and many of our
child care providers
we know are women and women of color
women are essential workers they are
moms
and grandmothers they are business
owners they are health care
professionals
and they have been on the front line of
this pandemic and this crisis
with this bill we are taking a
historical step
to not only help them recover we are
sending them hope and the tools to
rebuild
a stronger and more just economy for all
and with that i am very proud to yield
to
the outstanding chairman of ways and
means
dean of our delegation richie neal
otherwise known as a trillion-dollar man
thanks
and i want to begin by thanking the
speaker for the confidence that she
exhibited and the
ways and means committee and thank the
members of the ways and means committee
and their staff
assignments this is seismic legislation
and we're on the eve now of voting it
out of the house
awaiting the president's signature as i
heard stinney and the speaker talk about
members of congress and elected
officials in a lot of
purviews would they find it easy to be
at the
groundbreaking of the ribbon cutting and
they vote against the expenditure
it caused me a moment of nostalgia
because i joined the committee when mr
rostonkowski was the chairman
so what he would do is if he put the
item in for you
and then you voted against the bill he
just took it out no hearings no nothing
he just took it out
and i i think that we need to call
attention to those members
who take advantage of the legislation
because i don't know
that the 10 most consequential votes
that i've had in the 33 years that i've
been here now
that there'll be anything i will do
that'd be more important than this
on the child credit on the earned income
tax credit
child care credit the retention tax
credit
unemployment insurance
the checks of equity that will go out as
well
these provisions are going to change
lives it addresses the issue of income
inequality
20 percent of the american people
at the bottom end are going to directly
benefit from this immediately
that's how important again and how
consequential this legislation
is when you look at the numbers of what
we were able to do in the committee
on the affordable care act extending
these price supports to
to members of the american family and
something i'm really proud of and i want
to say this
again speakers reinforcement on this
what we did with the multi-employer
pension plans 500 plants
will be saved across the country we
added
decades to the solvency of the pension
benefit guarantee corporation
and for those who don't know what that
is that's the backstop for the american
pension system
when you think of people that are 75 or
76 or
well maybe into their 80s and 90s to be
told that their pensions were going to
be cut by 40 or 50 percent
this was not about malfeasance this was
not about corruption
it was about factors of the marketplace
mergers
acquisitions and deregulation
this is a huge victory and i'm very
proud of it so
we're delivering on our promises and i
can't wait
until tomorrow morning thank you my
friend john yarmouth who really did a
great job of
melding these different conflicts from
time to time together
thanks richie um i find myself in a
common
situation in that everything's been said
but not everyone said it
uh and and i'm last so i'm happy to do
that first
as i've told you personally and publicly
thank you for the
vote of confidence you have me to allow
me to participate in this
i want everybody to think back till
november 4th
the day after the election when
we didn't get the result we wanted in in
the house we didn't get the result we
wanted in the senate we thought
we would never have control of the
senate we weren't sure whether we had we
would have the presidency
and here just a few months later we're
about to pass one of the most
consequential pieces of legislation
in modern history um it's a it's nothing
short of a miracle that
we have gotten to this point and what
i am so thrilled about and so excited to
have been a part of
is that well i know there's a narrative
out there that democrats are in disarray
and and nowhere else in washington could
a 269-2 vote be considered a party in
disarray
if you had the senate house together
but we have come together as
as a party in the congress to
do something monumental but something
that also
clearly reflects our values as a party
a commitment to using government
to improve the lives of as many people
as possible
and i just got out of the rules
committee testifying before rules and it
was
almost comical to listen to the
republicans try to come up with
the appropriate attack on this
legislation they're having a hard time
doing it because again they voted for
most of this a number of times
but one of the one of the attacks was
bernie sanders just said this was one of
the most progressive pieces of
legislation ever passed
so they're trying to tie bernie sanders
around well of course it is
and the reason it is progressive is
because there isn't a dollar in this
bill that goes to the richest americans
not a dollar seventy percent of it goes
to
low and moderate income americans to
help them deal with the economic
tragedy of this pandemic
a very small amount goes to small
businesses an important
important amount but a small amount a
very large amount goes to
state city and local county and local
governments to help them
deal with the added costs of of the
covid with lost revenues
and with giving them opportunities to
help at their local level
in solving some of the local problems
that have resulted from the pandemic
so when we passed this bill tomorrow
i said after the affordable care act
that i didn't think i'd ever do
anything as significant in congress as i
did that day
i'm revising my uh my narrative now
and i think probably all of us who have
been around for the last
10 years or so have maybe given up hope
that we could do anything consequential
again in congress where we prove we can
we're all not just proud of what we're
about to do
but also energized by it and i think we
have in a sense
changed the landscape of the american
people's expectations of us
and that's that's both an opportunity is
daunting
challenge but also an opportunity and i
know that we're all committed to
doing everything we can to even enhance
our record on that score so
uh once again thrilled to be a part of
it and i'll turn it back to the speaker
thank you very much mr chairman and we
all give accolades uh
uh to mr yarmouth for his excellent work
over the years as chair
of the budget committee uh i think i
told you once before when i commended
him
for his great work and commended his
staff and thanked him for commending his
staff
in his closing remarks on the floor of
the house last week
he said that two weeks now a week and a
half ago
he said yes the staff deserves
so much credit and so does some bourbon
so he's true to his roots
of kentucky that went without saying
let me say that the staff of the
congress
personal stats and i say person
individual member staff
the staffs of the committees the staffs
of the leadership
offices works relentlessly really
24 7 on different shifts to make sure we
can meet
this deadline in a values-based
precise way because this is a very
complicated bill and it took our best
talent
all hands on deck so i salute the staff
i salute the members i salute our chairs
as you know i have always credited our
dazzling chairs with the excellent work
that they brought
to the table whether it was this bill or
other legislation related to crushing
the virus and
addressing the saving the lives and
livelihoods of the american people
but having said that i want to command
chuck schumer and the democrats in the
senate
for passing a very fine bill very much
like
ours some tweaks but nonetheless they
did a great job
in the senate but my praise right now
goes to the president of the united
states joe biden
this is the biden american rescue
plan it will be followed by the american
recovery
plan and it's about just that saving
lives and livelihoods
and giving people hope for the future
his presidency does
just that this legislation is a
reflection of his values now
it looks a lot like our heroes bill we
had quite a bit
quite a bit of this in our heroes bill
but i'm so glad our shared values plus
enhanced by uh maxine's and so many
uh other uh advances that are there
uh we couldn't be prouder than to be
associated him with it with him
in this and it's so sad because in all
of the bills as mr hoyer said
we've had bipartisanship signed by the
president we have a democratic president
all of a sudden many of the same
features of those other bills
in one size or another are in this bill
and the republicans have decided
they cannot be for it that's unfortunate
as i said
they'll take some credit for it in their
districts but um
we'll have more to say about that but i
do want to say this
i said earlier that there's some
legislation
like the butch lewis act that was so
much a part
of the pension bill and the equities
legislation that mr kyburn was so much a
part of with the congressional black
caucus
and the hispanic caucus and the asian
pacific called
shaping so that we have fairness in uh
in how the vaccines etc are distributed
in other
aspects of outreach for health
i just want to mention rosa delauro this
friday i think it is
the 18 years ago that she first
introduced
the child tax credit refundability bill
and here we are we we did get some of
that
under president bush in a bipartisan way
and now long overdue once again so i
want to salute her in that regard but we
can go on and on and we will we'll have
so many
uh presentations about this uh to uh
to praise our members because they all
made a valuable contribution to this
and we all are grateful to the president
of the united states for his great
leadership
any questions yes sir
you talk about the child tax credit yes
that's uh that lasts for a year so you
present a situation where
you're creating a fiscal cliff if it's
not extended
uh so all these families are talking
about lifting above the poverty scale
could get knocked right back down well
one thing that you should know about the
tax code
getting something out of the code is
oftentimes harder than getting something
in the code so i've already had some
thoughts about how we're going to expand
it and make it permanent
and i intend to share those in the near
future but what we did
is unlikely to go away you want to share
them now like how you pay for it
i've got some ideas i will share with
you at the right moment
this is a very important issue for us
and as you know this is a covert related
legislation
so uh that yes uh chad thank you good
afternoon
you talked about the republicans might
take credit for some of this
in a couple of down days numbers the
senate confirms
marcia fudge and deb holland here what
does that mean with trying to
move some of the other parts of your
agenda if you're down right down to the
edge
and you're not getting any help from the
other side of the audience
we haven't we're going to have elections
we are already in the course of one in
louisiana
where mr uh cedric richmond's
person who will come in in that capacity
will be here
and then when they are confirmed and
hopefully it will be soon so that they
can assume they're
places in the cabinet of the united
states uh
they will have elections and they'll be
replaced
on some of these other initiatives
there's not going to be a problem
garrett
um madam speaker i think even last fall
when the last covet relief bill passed
you were already talking about having to
do another bill
in the new administration do you think
this is the last
primarily covid bill that you'll have to
take up
you're just gonna have to ask the virus
if it stops mutating
if it stops spreading and therefore
mutating then uh
this will be and some of the provisions
in here
uh that have a fuse like the uh the
expanded tax
the enhanced enhanced
unemployment insurance benefit that goes
until the fall
just we'll just see where we are then
but it's not anything anybody can
predict
it's just a question of the science and
we will
have legislation to address it for as
long as it's there any kind of
can i can i ask that a different way i
mean you've talked about the importance
of crushing the virus
are you confident the provisions in this
bill can do that
yes again the the what is interesting
about this virus
is that it's resourceful it mutates
it has variance and so too must we
be resourceful and resilient in how we
deal with it
but we will be on top of it
yes ma'am last question madam speaker
thank you are house democratic
leaders concerned about maybe losing
some numbers progressives
in this revised foreign
these leaders are concerned about what
our house democratic leader is concerned
about losing any members
i think we only lost two on the first
time
and i think we at least cut it in half
this time
so we have a 50 increase in the number
of people who
left but let me just say our members
have
a good judgment and they know that this
legislation
is just something historic and
transformative to return to those two
words
and we are not giving up on the fight
for 15 we've all been involved in it
for years and we will continue to be
involved and i'll talk more about that
at my press conference on thursday once
we pass this bill and the rest
but uh no they know how i mean it's hard
for us to understand how the republicans
can vote against
this bill because it has such an impact
on their constituents
our members are well aware of that and
also
the value the intellectual excellence of
what is
is in the legislation so we we feel
pretty confident
about it and uh we thank you for your
attention to our
i'm so excited i just can't hide it kind
of attitude thank you
you